Joe Jonas reveals he's upped his workout
regimen eg spoke with the singer and his
band dnce ahead of the release of their
self-titled debut album where they
dished on how they stay in shape it's a
lot of this kind of motion yeah yeah
that really helps with the arms yes I
think for all of us we run around like
maniacs on stage and that alone is
probably our cardio enough to get us
kind of in that shape
I definitely like obviously like upped
it up a bunch we travel the trainer and
she like works us out really hard I mean
when we have free time because obviously
our times are really short but we try to
get it in here
Pizza Joe also revealed he got to see
the newest addition to the Jonas family
brother Kevin and sister-in-law
Danielle's new bundle of joy
Valentina ahead of the interview yeah I
got to fly in and flew in early to spend
time with my niece and it's unbelievable
you know I'm so like nervous holding her
cuz she's so small but it's really cool
to see you know Alina who's the older
sister taking care of her and Mike
watching after it's really a beautiful
thing